in the previous session we saw what a
symmetric matrix is a square matrix a is
symmetric if a transpose is equal to a
in this session we will look at what a
skew symmetric matrix is the definition
goes like this
a square matrix a is skew symmetric if a
transpose is equal to negative a let me
repeat a square matrix is skew symmetric
if its transpose is equal to it's
negative a simple example would
definitely help us understand better is
this matrix a skew symmetric so we will
find a transpose first and then negative
of a if they are equal then we can say
that matrix a is skew symmetric let's
find a transpose first the first row
becomes the first column 1 4 and the
second row becomes the second column 0
-1 this is a transpose and what about
negative a find the negative of a matrix
we negate each of its elements 1 will be
minus 1 4 will become minus 4 negative
of 0 is 0 and negative of minus 1 is 1
are these two matrices equal 4 2
matrices to be equal their orders have
to be equal and their corresponding
elements also have to be equal the
orders of a transpose and negative a are
equal but are the corresponding elements
equal 1 is not equal to minus 1 even if
one set of corresponding elements are
not equal we can say that the matrices
are not equal we don't need to check the
rest so a transpose and negative a are
not equal and hence matrix a is not skew
symmetric this tells us something
interesting I want you to focus on the
diagonal elements of a by diagonal I
mean the leading diagonal notice that
the diagonal elements do not change for
the transpose
1 and minus 1 1 and minus 1 and for
negative a just like the other elements
the elements in the diagonal are also
negated and what is the condition for a
matrix to be a skew symmetrical it says
that a transpose should be equal to
negative a which means all corresponding
elements must be equal can the diagonal
elements of these two matrices ever be
equal let's say the diagonal elements of
a matrix were 2 & 4 for a transpose the
diagonal elements would be 2 & 4 & 4
negative a the diagonal elements would
be minus 2 and minus 4 not equal so if
the diagonal elements are nonzero the
matrix can never be a skew symmetric
let's zoom out and write the condition
for the matrix to be skew symmetric the
diagonal elements have to be 0 if the
diagonal elements are nonzero the matrix
can never be skew symmetric look at
matrix B is it skew symmetric it is a
square matrix and the leading diagonal
elements are also 0 so it may be skew
symmetric so let's find B transpose and
negative B pause the video and try to
find each ok B transpose first the first
row will become the first column 0 2 and
the second row will become the second
column minus 2 0 & 4 minus B we negate
each element negative of 0 is 0 negative
of 2 is minus 2 negative of minus 2 is 2
and negative of 0 is 0 are these two
matrices equal yes the order as well as
the corresponding elements are equal so
B is the skew symmetric matrix
what about matrix C is it skew symmetric
it is a square matrix and it's leading
diagonal elements are zero so it may be
a skew symmetric matrix we find C
transpose first the first row is written
as the first column and the second row
is written as the second column this is
C transpose and what about negative C
each element when negated gives us this
the negative of 0 is 0
negative of 1 is minus 1 negative of 4
is minus 4 and the negative of 0 is 0
clearly these two matrices are not equal
matrix C is not skew symmetric